[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
VISHAVJIT SINGH: Thank
you, [INAUDIBLE]..
Thank you, everyone,
for being here.
And so I am going
to be talking today
about labels, stereotypes,
and creating stories.
Let me get started, actually.
So from the day we're born
labels are placed upon us.
So I was born in a
Washington DC hospital,
and one of the first
things that get
placed upon you, at least in the
United States, is a race label.
So if you look at your
birth certificate,
there's actually a race column.
And interestingly, in my case,
most people cannot get what
my race actually says.
Anybody want to take a guess
what my race column says
on my birth certificate?
AUDIENCE: Asian?
VISHAVJIT SINGH: Asian.
That's a good guess.
AUDIENCE: South Asian?
VISHAVJIT SINGH: South Asian.
Another good guess.
Incorrect guesses.
Anybody else?
Think a bigger
demographic group.
Very big.
AUDIENCE: Chinese?
VISHAVJIT SINGH: No.
So let me answer that
question for you.
And I'll show you my birth
certificate for that, actually.
Bottom left corner.
I'm white.
And I know you probably are
thinking, wait a minute,
that doesn't make sense.
So let me put it this way.
The label "white" itself
doesn't make sense.
There are no white people.
Technically, there
are no white people.
If you look at a
white piece of paper,
I don't think you know
any other human being
on this planet who looks white.
Neither are there
people who look black.
But there's a long history
behind why we have terms
like "black" and "white."
A long history of
demeaning people,
defining them, confining
them, justifying slavery.
But that's not where
I'm going to go today.
But I just want you to
sort of, for a moment,
realize I had this label placed
upon me because technically,
in the pseudoscience of
racism, all South Asians
are considered Caucasian.
And we, as Americans, confuse
Caucasians for white people.
Not all Caucasians
are white people.
So technically--
just remember this,
for all of you who
hail from South Asia--
you're white people.
This is me in elementary school.
And so I spent the
first four years
of my life in Washington
DC, Maryland area,
moved with my parents to India--
who were from India.
And among many other labels,
one of the things that happens
is you follow your
parents' lifestyle.
So whatever their faith
or belief system is,
you don't get to choose it.
You get to kind of follow it.
At least in the first few years.
I did that.
So you see that bun
on top of my head.
My faith at the time
happened to be a Sikh faith,
a young religion from India.
And as part of that faith
we don't cut our hair.
Both men and women,
we keep long hair.
Boys keep their hair in
a bun, including men,
but as young boys we wear
these little, small turbin
called "patkas."
The reason I'm showing
this photograph to you
is for another reason though.
You notice I started wearing
glasses really early on.
Now, glasses are considered
pretty cool these days.
You have a lot of
different brand names.
Everybody is sporting
new glasses all the time.
Well, when I was a young
boy, putting glasses on
was not a cool thing.
It unfortunately made me very
open to targeting by bullies.
And not only bullies,
actually, out on the streets
or in school.
It was actually loved ones at
home, parents, uncles, aunts,
cousins who just
thought, you know what?
You don't look good, man.
Somehow physically there
is something not acceptable
about your appearance.
And so what happened is,
after a few months and years
people started using
the word ugly to refer
to me in comparison
to my brother,
who happened to be handsome.
I knew that.
My brother knew that.
But we didn't have to
say that to each other.
But unfortunately society has
to project its insecurities,
their own fears and anxieties.
So that's how a lot
of my loved ones
kept telling me as
I was growing up.
Something's wrong
with you, Vishavjit.
You don't look good.
You're an ugly kid.
So by the time I was a
high-schooler I got convinced.
I bought into that label.
So my struggle was, OK, how
do I overcompensate now?
So how do I prove my worth?
So the way I proved my--
the way I choose
to prove my worth
was, well, let me see if
I can study really hard
and go to one of the best
universities on the planet.
And that's how I'm
going to prove my worth.
So that was-- as a young
boy I have these labels
placed upon me, and
now those labels
are driving my
life-changing decisions.
What do I need to do?
Where do I need to go to school?
So that became a vulnerability.
And that's something
we all carry.
So this was a man-made,
humankind-made vulnerability
that I had to carry with me.
And then something
drastic happens
by the time I go to University
of California, Santa Barbara.
This is sophomore year.
But before I actually give
you a little back story
on this I want to
sort of talk very
briefly about another
impact labels can have.
So I mentioned I
happened to be Sikh.
That's one of the
labels people put on me.
I happened to be of Sikh faith.
As a young boy,
in the year 1984,
I happened to be in New Delhi
when the Indian prime minister
was killed.
And for a few days in the
first week in November anybody
who had that label on them,
Sikhs, mostly men, turban
beards, were targeted and
thousands were killed.
They were burned alive,
purely because they
had that label upon them.
And unfortunately those
things happen today as well.
You can look at many
different parts of the world
where powers to be
decide, here's a group.
That belongs to this label,
and we'll target them.
So moving fast-forward,
this is me.
And obviously you see that
I don't have my turban here.
So when I came back to the
US-- the land of my birth,
my homeland, however
you want to put it--
I came to Los Angeles first.
And most people out
on the streets of LA
greeted me by
calling me "genie,"
"raghead," "go back home."
Some people just
laughed in my face.
So I am a teenager about
to go to college, insecure,
not having a great sense of
who I am, low self-esteem.
And I'm like, well,
how do I fit in?
How do I change myself?
So the only thing I had
in my control at the time
is, well, I'll
take my turban off,
which meant a lot to
me and my parents.
But I didn't tell my parents.
And then a few weeks
later I cut my hair off.
So I told my mother
first, who was
across on the other
side of the globe,
and I had her tell
the rest of my family.
And it kind of worked.
So people now stopped
staring at me.
They confused me
for being Hispanic.
People started coming up
to me speaking in Spanish.
So that's sort of another
sort of impact of--
now new labels come in, coming
in and sort of defining me.
And I didn't mind those labels.
And I think what would help me
for a certain amount of time
was, now people are not seeing
me as "the extreme other."
So it felt good.
It felt good to be invisible.
That was a desirable thing
for me to be at that time.
I don't want to stand out.
I don't want people to see me.
So that process actually
went on for a long time.
And there was something
that I call a time
machine that came to my rescue.
And I'm not talking about a
physical electronic mechanical
time machine.
I like to call books
my time machine.
So I fell in love with books.
And believe it or not,
when I was a young kid
and until I went to the
University of California Santa
Barbara and then
Berkeley for grad school,
I had not read a single
book cover-to-cover.
I just didn't grow up in a
family where books were valued.
So when I went to college
I started reading books.
It just opened up my horizons.
I mean, I was reading
history and science fiction.
And it just kind of
opened up my world
to incredible possibilities.
Right?
So I started experimenting with
Buddhism, Taoist meditations.
And eventually on way,
with a shaved head,
mohawk for a few hours,
almost 10 years later
I decided, you know what?
I'm going to embrace my
faith that I was born into.
On my own for the
first time, nobody
is telling me what to do.
This is what I'm going to try.
So as part of that
faith I embraced--
I started growing my hair long.
And unless you've cut
your hair really short
and really grown it
to the full length,
it takes a long time
to grow your hair.
It took me two years.
So for the first time in
10 years, August 2001--
by this time I'm living
in Westchester County
just north of New York City.
And so I don this
turban, and we all
know what happened
a month later.
9/11 happened.
So I saw the towers come down
on the big screen in a cafeteria
at work, and within
hours I had coworkers
who were giving
me strange looks,
bloodshot eyes, staring me down.
And as the news
was trickling in,
I knew I'm not going to be safe.
So I suddenly became
that "ultimate other."
And within hours I had a friend
who was pulled out of a train
just because he had
a turban and a beard
somewhere in the
American Northeast.
He actually made CNN.
He was on news, having
been arrested because--
just he had a
turban and a beard.
So that label-- being brown,
but especially with a turban
and beard--
became the "ultimate
other" label in America.
And in some ways it still is.
So what came to my rescue
is, I saw a cartoon--
an editorial cartoon.
A few weeks after 9/11 hate
crimes had risen, skyrocketing.
Anybody who was perceived to
be the other, Hispanic men,
Muslim men, South Asians,
Hindus, Christians.
As long as you were
brown and fitted
that "other" label, fair game.
Let's arrest you, punch
you, call you names.
So I saw a cartoonist
who's based out
of San Francisco, Mark Fiore.
He created a cartoon called
"Find the Terrorist."
And he had this fast-rotating
image of different characters.
And the whole point there
was-- you get to click.
There's a Sikh guy,
there's a Hispanic man,
there's a Muslim man,
there's a white man.
And you were getting
introduced to these men.
And the point was--
these are all Americans.
And it turns out
the white man, who
happened to be a guy
whose name was John
and he had committed
a hate crime
against a fellow
American, and he
happened to be a
terrorist at that moment,
because he was
committing hate crimes.
Right?
But we don't use
that terminology
for people who
commit hate crimes.
So for me there were, like,
bells that went off in my head
that, hey, Mark's
actually portraying
Sikhs and others in cartoons.
And I had never seen
people who looked
like me in editorial cartoons.
And I said, you know what?
Maybe I should start
creating cartoons.
So I taught myself.
I started going on the internet
and I started teaching myself
how to do cartooning.
And really not physically
drawing-- that's
not really the
art of cartooning.
It's catching
contradictions in society.
So this is one of the first
cartoons that I created.
It's an eye chart.
And the principal
message here is,
we judge people all the time.
We place labels all the time.
Right?
But you don't know these people.
And so the whole point here is,
look, unless you ask me what
my story is, don't judge me.
Right?
But unfortunately
we all do this.
So I do cartoons based
on my experiences,
based on news stories.
So this is really one of
the coolest men who I've
created many cartoons about.
His name is Fanja Singh.
He is of Indian descent.
He's a British citizen now.
He moved to the UK
in his late 80s.
Lost his wife, so he spent
some time with his sons there.
And he fell in
love with running.
He became a competitive
marathon runner.
He started breaking
world records.
He did that until the
age of 100 years old.
He went all over the world.
He still runs.
He's 105-years-old.
He's still alive.
He raises money for poor
people in Africa and Asia.
When he came to New
York, by the way, when
he was running the
marathon there,
he was called Osama bin
Laden by some people.
We all know "The Scream."
I am, as I mentioned, a
shy guy who will not--
if you abuse me, if you call
me names, chances are I won't--
I'll try to maybe engage you,
but if you are not interested
I won't say anything in
return, but I'll go home
and I'll start
creating cartoons.
And that's how I
feel like at times.
I really feel like
screaming at people,
but I try to pour my
frustrations through cartoons.
So that's how I
feel like at times.
Anybody here ever seen a hot
air balloon with a bun on top?
I bet you you have not.
Right?
But now you have.
And I would say this.
This is possible, physically.
From an engineering
perspective, this is possible.
And the whole concept
here is, look,
have hot air balloons with buns.
And I'm sure people
are going to wonder,
why do we have a bun on
top of hot air balloon?
Well, then you get to explain.
It's a Sikh hot air balloon.
So, anybody who wants
to copy this idea,
it's not copyrighted.
You can go ahead and
make a lot of money.
Just give little
reference to, hey,
this was an idea that
Vishavjit came up with
and I bought it from there.
So Googlers, take
a note of that.
So talking about labels--
so bringing it
back to real life.
This man was a superintendent
in New York City schools
in the mid-2000s.
New York City is one of the most
diverse places on this planet.
And believe it or not, even
there today more than half
of Sikh kids who go to school
report getting bullied.
That's a staggering number.
Half of Sikh boys
and girls are bullied
in schools in New York City.
I can't even imagine what
happens in certain other places
in America.
It took almost a
year to convince
this man, who was
running our school
districts at the
time, that let's
have a web portal so parents
and kids can anonymously
put complaints in so somebody
can do something about it.
He was not convinced.
It took civil action
threats of lawsuits
before he was convinced.
Those are challenges-- and
I'm not saying he's a bad man.
But those are challenges
we face in society,
where even today good men
and women-- educated--
take a lot of convincing with
data and persuasion, in person
at times, to say, look,
we need to have resources
so we can share data about
things that are not good for us
as a society.
This is another true story
out of Quebec, Canada,
a French and
English-speaking province.
Unfortunately, like many
other places on this planet,
diversity is something
that many societies don't
want to embrace, or they want to
embrace it on their own terms.
So Quebec, a few years ago there
was a Quebec Soccer Federation
for young kids,
middle-schoolers.
And that federation decided
they were going to pass a rule.
If you are a kid who has
a turban on his head,
you cannot play soccer.
The reason was, you are a danger
to yourself and other kids.
In reality they wanted
to pass a policy
saying Muslim kids
are not allowed
because Quebec is having
"issues," quote unquote,
with Muslims.
But they wanted to be
democratic about their racism
because if they said
Muslim kids are not allowed
they're opening themselves
up to lawsuits, so they
wanted to be--
they were clever.
They were crafty.
Let's just make a rule for
all religious artifacts
and symbols.
So Jewish kids, Sikh kids,
Christian kids, not allowed.
And this policy probably
is still in place.
But those are challenges.
You know?
People use data and intelligence
to actually figure out
ways of using racism
to their benefit.
Another story out of a city that
has been in the news last year
quite a bit-- what
comes to mind when
you think of Charlottesville?
Anybody?
AUDIENCE: Probably the march.
VISHAVJIT SINGH: The march.
A lot of people will say
"KKK," "white supremacy."
It might be true for
that period of time,
but Charlottesville actually
has a really unique distinction
in America.
It's the first
city ever anywhere
in America that had a Sikh
mayor with a turban and beard.
And most people would--
if I were to say,
take a guess, what city would
have done that, you would
imagine cities in the North.
You would not think
of a city in the South
that would have done this.
And those are stereotypes we
have of places in America,
saying, everybody
in the South is not
as progressive as everybody
who lives in the North.
Well, you know what?
It's not true.
Life's more complicated.
Charlottesville has
this unique sort of fact
about itself that
it had a Sikh mayor.
First turbaned and
bearded mayor in America.
So I thought that
was really cool.
So here's another story
that did not make the news.
I saw it on a blog by NAACP,
which is the first civil rights
organization that was
representing African-Americans.
A Sikh man drove
through Mississippi--
he's a commercial truck driver.
Flat tire, waited
for cops to come.
And usually what do cops do
when you have a flat tire?
They come and help you.
Well, cops saw him.
They judged him, stereotyped
him, labeled him.
Freaked out, physically
searched him--
they should not have done that--
found a religious artifact
on him, a kirpan, which
is a religious dagger,
call him a terrorist a bunch
of times, arrested him.
He was presented in
front of a judge,
and the judge said to
him, excuse me sir,
you cannot enter this courtroom.
Why?
Because you have that
rag on your head.
And if you're going
to enter my courtroom,
you're going to have
to leave that rag off.
And, ladies and
gentlemen, this is
somebody who has gone
through law school, who's
taken an oath to defend
our constitution and laws.
And this is happening--
these cases have happened
in Michigan, in Ohio.
And they still happen.
They just don't make the news.
Now, does it make
these people racist?
That's not what's important.
They engaged in racist moments,
and that's what's important.
And we need to deal
with those situations.
These men need training.
They need education.
And unfortunately, in this
case, none of that happened.
The Sikh man hired
some lawyers, NAACP
and a few other
organizations, and he
got those cases written off.
So we have a challenge
where we have
a lot of intelligent
people, good people--
I would call them
good people, even
these people who
need education, who
need to hear stories of people
who look different but share
a lot in common with them.
Talking about race and policing.
We've had a lot of stories
about black men and boys
getting killed at
the hands of police.
Right?
And amazingly, if you
look at a lot of surveys,
even today, majority
of white people
have a very different perception
than majority of black people.
They just cannot come to an
agreement that we have a race
problem in America today.
They'll agree we have
some, but not to the extent
that it's leading to police
officers shooting black men
and boys.
So I'll share this
next cartoon with you.
This is in response
to an NPR story,
where the city of Los Angeles
is doing community policing.
And as part of that community
policing a lawyer got access--
private access to cops.
Not recorded, no names, nothing.
Let's just have a
heart-to-heart conversation.
Right?
Nobody is going to talk
about, hey, who this guy was,
what your name is.
And just about every police
officer, white or black,
said this in the
privacy of these spaces,
that "I fear black people.
I fear black men, and
I fear black boys."
That's an incredible admission.
And I'm not stunned.
I'm not surprised.
So imagine a police officer.
One of the hardest
jobs in America.
You're putting your
life on the line.
You go out.
You're trained.
You're heavily armed, and
you're also armed with fear.
Of course you're
going to sometimes,
in difficult
situations-- you're going
to imagine a black man
who's going into his pocket
for getting out
his ID and you're
going to think he
is taking out a gun.
Because that's what fear does.
And it is not a surprise-- it's
not an accident that people who
look like me don't get shot.
White men, brown meant, Sikh
men don't get shot by cops.
Black men do.
Because in many cases,
including myself,
we're raised with a certain
fear of black people.
And unless we have these
conversations out in public,
we will have more black men and
boys who are going to get shot,
until we start having these
conversations in public.
So here's an interesting story.
Joe Budden is a hip-hop
artist who, a couple of years
ago, found himself
in an airport.
He was at a carousel
waiting for his luggage.
He spotted a Sikh man
who looks like my father.
White beard, dapperly-dressed.
And Joe Budden thought,
hey, you know what?
I'm going to
stereotype this guy.
He's not American.
I'm an American.
So he took a photo, tweeted
it with a caption saying,
"not on my watch, homeboy."
He labeled him as a "suspicious"
terrorist character,
tweeted it.
People loved it.
They retweeted it.
Thousand of times
it was retweeted.
Until somebody caught onto
it, brought to his notice.
And this was big news
for a couple of days.
And so eventually he apologized.
And I think he apologized
after two days.
I don't feel it was
a genuine apology.
He apologized because he
wanted to save his brand.
That's what a lot of people do.
And one of the
reasons I show this
is, stereotyping and racism
is not a one-way street.
It happens all over the place.
I stereotype people as well.
And just because
you get stereotyped
doesn't mean you don't
stereotype other people.
This is a very
self-explanatory cartoon.
I get asked by people all
the time, where are you from?
And I'm like, well, I'm kind
of from all over the place.
Born in DC, lived
all over the place.
I am from New York now.
And they're like, no, no, no.
But where are you really from?
I'm like, well, I
know what you're
trying to get to so let
me just cut it short.
My parents are from India.
And they're like, great.
You're not from here.
And, I mean, it's just absurd.
There are Sikhs
who have been here
for three or four generations.
Americans are not
defined by their looks.
How do you know when you look at
somebody that they're American?
You can't.
But we do it all
the time anyways.
All right.
So Captain America in
a turban and a beard.
A few years ago I went to
a New York City Comic Con
as an exhibitor selling my art.
The first Captain America
movie had come out,
and I drew him in
turban and beard,
in case you have not
figured that out already.
And I envisioned
a Captain America
who's going to find hidden
bias in a turban and beard.
People loved it.
They were like, wow,
this is really great.
A photographer in
passing said, Vishavjit,
why don't you come next year
dressed up as Captain America?
And you know what
my response was?
I don't think so.
Because I had body image issues.
I had been bullied all
my life for being skinny.
So I'm like, I'm not doing this.
And there was a second reason.
I was getting called "Osama
bin Laden," "Taliban,"
"you're not from here," "go
back home" all the time.
Even now most
people stare at me.
And I'm just like-- and
I've gotten used to it.
But I'm like, why would I wear
a leotard, skintight uniform
and walk out and have every
eye that is not on me on me?
So it took a year
for this photographer
to convince me that
I should do this.
So I had to prepare at home
in front of the mirror.
She got me a uniform
from Hong Kong,
a teenager size she
could not find in the US.
I went to Sports
Authority goods store,
and I bought myself
baseball and football pads,
shoved them in my uniform
to make myself look big.
My wife had to tell me, you look
like a cartoon-- actual cartoon
now.
So if you're going
to walk out you're
going to have to either
be you, Vishavjit Singh,
or you're not going to do this.
So I did step out, June
2013, as Captain America.
Incredibly nervous, not knowing
what people are going to think.
Are they going to
really be offended?
Are they going to call me names?
And something really weird and
magical and strange happened.
People embraced me as if I was
a real superhero character.
People hugged me.
Strangers hugged me.
I got pulled into weddings,
believe it or not,
stranger weddings.
Cops came up to me and
took photos with me.
That never happens to me,
certainly in New York City.
Cops don't do that to anybody.
Not in civilian clothes.
I got access to a
fire department truck
that was managing a parade.
They gave me this truck
for 20 minutes on my own.
I had this truck.
I pretended I was driving it.
I was jumping in and out.
That was my privilege
for those 20 minutes,
in that fictional uniform
where I could ask these things
and they were given to me.
That's the power of images.
That's the power of stories.
Fictional stories that we
take sometimes very seriously.
Because Captain America
is our super hero.
It's an American super hero.
But guess what?
Captain America does not exist.
Right?
But you can trick our perceptual
apparatus into thinking,
oh, Vishavjit Singh is the
coolest guy in the world.
He's the coolest American.
I want to share a quick story
with you about this young boy.
He saw me for about
10 minutes posing
and he's like,
what are you doing?
I said, I am Captain
America for the day.
He's like, no you're not.
I said, why not?
And he goes, you're not white.
I said, I know I'm not white.
But Captain America is
a fictional character.
He could be-- he
could be a woman.
He could be black, Hispanic.
So he thought about it
and he goes, black, yes.
Hispanic, maybe.
Turban and beard, no.
And he was not being
malicious, by the way.
He was just being honest.
He couldn't fathom, as a
middle-schooler in America--
he had never seen
anybody who looked
like me in a superior uniform.
So I said, I'm not offended.
Don't worry about it.
But keep in mind for
the rest of your life,
in the computer of
your head there's
an image of me as
Captain America,
and you'll never be able to
take that out of your head.
So maybe next time you see
somebody who looks like me,
you'll think of
Captain America first.
So that's the power of images.
So here are some labels.
What you see on the
left here is labels
that the world has placed upon
me in many shapes and forms.
Some of them are benign.
Some are pretty offensive.
Then you see that
circle on the right
and you would think like,
well, you know, that's
more Vishavjit Singh.
That's labels I've
placed upon myself.
And one would think that's
more of Vishavjit Singh,
but I would actually make the
argument that actually I'm
none of these labels.
I'm informed by how I've
responded to these labels.
How I've maneuvered,
how I've managed them.
We all do this every
day, by the way.
I'm not the only
one who's doing it.
I am who I am, I'm standing
here today in large part
because these labels on the
left were placed by other people
upon me, and I had to
figure out a way of,
how do I respond to them.
Right?
And they expose
my vulnerability.
And what came to my rescue,
strangers, art, and sometimes
tragedies.
9/11, surviving a
genocide, feeling
like I am the most unwanted man
in America by fellow Americans.
Those things actually became
moments where I could say,
you know what?
Maybe I can do something new.
So let me actually
ask you a question.
Let me move back here.
Show of hands, how many
of you would say you
engage in stereotyping
other people and cultures?
Show of hands?
Most hands have gone up.
When I pose this
question in most crowds,
most hands do not go up.
Right?
People-- they don't
want to acknowledge
that they have stereotypes.
It's a vulnerability.
So let me share
with you a workshop
that I ran a few weeks ago.
This is a private school near
Boston, very diverse group.
And I hosted his
workshop, and we
talked about our stereotypes.
So these are some
positive responses
from young, diverse
group of high-schoolers.
These are positive
stereotypes, that
can be very damaging as well.
And then we moved on to
negative stereotypes.
This was a very long list.
And this was a repetitive
list, meaning that many of them
had these responses.
Just read this list.
I mean, what was amazing
about these kids is not
that they stand out from
you, that they are racist
or they have a
stereotyping problem.
What they did is they opened
their hearts in that moment,
their vulnerability,
and said, look,
I'll honestly share
this with you.
This was an anonymous exercise.
Each one of them responded
to this question,
and we read this out loud.
And all of us in America,
around the globe,
we all have stereotypes.
It's just that some of us
are going to acknowledge it,
some of us are not
willing to acknowledge.
And until we do that we're
going to have challenges.
Right?
I'm presuming most of you have
gone through the unconscious
bias at work here at Google?
Show of hands.
Yeah?
So let me sort of say,
sort of in conclusion here,
it's quite obvious
labels are data points.
And I know Google is really
big on collecting data.
But my focus is on storytelling.
And one other things that I
think we lack in our approaches
to diversity at times is--
certainly data has
it's importance.
It's critical.
We have to talk about data.
Right?
But I think there's another
very powerful factor,
and that's story-telling,
our stories.
And what I mean by
stories is, we're
all walking, talking stories.
Each one of you is stories.
You're not really defined
by labels and, you know,
the "race" labels and "where
you're from" necessarily.
You guys are stories.
And those stories
have ups and downs.
They have sad moments,
happy moments.
They have strengths, they
have vulnerabilities.
And those vulnerabilities--
typically we
see them as negative things.
We see them as
negative data points.
And I would contend those
vulnerabilities are actually
what define you, what
make you who you are.
They actually define
a lot of decisions
you make in your lives.
This is where you're
going to live,
what you're going to do
in life, where you're
going to buy a house, who you're
going to give your business to.
Even at work
implicitly those biases
come into shape and form.
And many of them are implicit.
You're not even aware
yourself that you
have these biases, right?
So I would contend that,
if we were to really engage
our vulnerabilities, there's a
lot of connections you'll find.
Almost everybody who's
here in this room
and who's hearing this video of
this talk, I can assure you--
you sit down honestly
with yourself
and you can make a very
long list of stereotypes
that are placed upon you and
you place upon other people.
And we all have them.
And that's what we
need to start sharing.
For me, I would
contend, stories are
creative personal
entrepreneurship.
They have a profound
potential to change
our lives, and
the workplace, out
on the streets, our social,
cultural, political future.
And we all need to--
I mean, we need
to really embrace
our stories and their honesty.
Not just as, hey, this is what
I do, this is where I'm from.
Really open up to our
strengths and weaknesses
and our vulnerabilities, and it
will open up to possibilities.
And it's personal
entrepreneurship.
And I'm using that
word intentionally
because "entrepreneur" literally
means, "bearer of risk."
And until we take those risks
of being honest with ourself,
first and foremost,
and then honest
with our fellow
coworkers, we're not
going to bring
about earnest change
where things like black
man getting shot by cops
is not going to stop.
So to you, as a company,
and especially to you as
individuals, as members
of broader society,
I wish you an incredible
amount of success
in being those creative
personal entrepreneurs.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So what I'm going to do is--
I fortunately also,
as part of my work,
have been featured in
a few documentaries.
One of them is known as the
"Red, White, and Beard,"
which you can
actually go on Google.
I should say, YouTube,
which is Google property.
Just search for "Red,
White, and Beard,"
and you will see a
short 10-minute video
where I actually dressed
up as Captain America
and walked out on
streets of New York City
and I started engaging people,
started asking them questions.
And there's another
documentary that
is now doing the rounds
at film festivals, "Drawn
Together: Comics,
Diversity, and Stereotypes."
That features me along with
a couple of other artists
who are tackling issues of
diversity and stereotypes.
And we are fortunate to have the
director of that film, Harleen
[INAUDIBLE] here, so
she's going to take
a few minutes to
introduce that project
and show you a quick trailer.
HARLEEN SINGH: Hi everyone.
My name is Harleen,
and I'm a storyteller.
So taking off from
what Vishavjit was just
talking about, I think
stories are really important.
Just take a moment.
Maybe just close your eyes
for a second and think of--
you are in Trader Joe's
and picking up bananas,
and somebody is actually
making monkey noises just
because you're holding bananas.
Or think of another
situation where you're just
taking a walk down the beach.
You are just
dressed up casually,
but somebody is actually calling
you a terrorist or a towel head
or a rag head for that matter.
Or for that matter,
let's picture
this, that you just had a baby.
It's a small, loving child, and
you're giving all the attention
to that child.
But yet you want to do something
different with your life.
But just because you're a
mom, your life is finished.
Yes, these are labels.
These are stereotypes.
These are stereotypes that we,
as a society, place on others.
And one of the things that, as
a storyteller, I want to do--
and I wish everybody, each
one of us, can do in this room
as well--
is to shun stereotypes.
It's a strange thing that
when somebody actually
stereotypes us we are
like, hm-mm, don't do that.
You know what?
I was in a bad mood that day.
Or you know what?
That's not who I am.
You misjudged me.
But when it comes to others,
we really want to place labels.
Oh, pregnant women
probably can do it.
Oh, this person is driving
a car really badly.
Definitely a lady.
There's no question about it.
Or there is a child who is
actually just working around
and you're like, my god these
parents must be terrible
because of the way the
child is being treated.
Or if there's a black
man just walking around
you're like, oh,
definitely a drugist.
He just can't have the
money to pay for what
he's just shopping around.
This is something that we,
as a society, need to change.
And as storytellers we
want to show examples
of people who have done it.
And the story that
you'll probably
just watch a glimpse of--
the film, which is called "Drawn
Together; Comics, Diversity,
and Stereotypes"--
the film shows that there
are three people who
are using comics as
a medium to challenge
this notion of stereotypes.
And sometimes we feel
that if they can do it
with just a pen in
hand, a lot of us
can do it with so
many other means.
So the goal is
that, when you watch
the trailer you go back home,
read about these things,
and then try and
make a difference
about this particular
subject of people around you.
Make a difference
in your society.
Make a difference in yourself.
Change is what happens when
you take that first step.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Comics are a great
way to comment on stuff
that's happening in the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[BUZZING]
[SWAT]
- Creating cartoons allowed me
to channel my anger with how
I was being perceived, have
been perceived all my life.
You're not American.
- As a woman creator, the idea
that maybe my stories would
naturally be romance stories
or soap-opera-type stories.
In reality, I like
big adventure stories
with action and explosions and
super-big, fun, crazy stuff.
- What I wanted to do was
make a commentary on race
without making a
commentary on race.
There's a lot of people
who have had hardships
before Sikhs came here.
Get out of your
comfort zone, which
means do things that haven't
been done by a community
before.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Collectively, if we are
all allowed to do what I do,
which is make stories
from my perspective,
showing that I am more than
what is depicted in mainstream
media, then we can really
have a decent discussion
about solving the problems and
issues of race and stereotypes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]